partenaires qui étaient impliqué dans
cette ville là qu'ils en aurait pris le
contrôle ils ont publié aussi une photo
qu'on retrouve sur la chaîne télégram
lors du propriétaire du groupe Wagner où
on les verrait avec Monsieur Prigogine
justement à l'intérieur d'une mine de
sel l'Ukraine mais en doute le densité
de cette photo moi j'aimerais avoir
votre avis jusqu'à quel point on peut
croire les affirmations du groupe Wagner
mais c'est actuellement il y a deux
types de batailles qui se s'effectue
dans cette région là backmouth et c'est
la première c'est vraiment prendre le
contrôle aussi de ville là parce que
elle est un nœud ferroviaire et aussi
vers Donets ce qui est important à
maintenir si les Ukrainiens poussent
éventuellement vers Daniel ils doivent
contrôler cette ce secteur là l'autre
bataille qui se fait à backmouth et la
région c'est la bataille entre le groupe
Wagner et les forces russes ça c'est
notionnel un peu et je m'explique c'est
que Wagner veut absolument avoir une
victoire et cette victoire-là viendrait
arrêter un peu les pertes et les
défaites que l'armée russe a connu
depuis le début de cette guerre-là et le
groupe Wagner à ce moment ressortirait
comme un groupe plus efficace que
l'armée russe elle-même alors l'armée
russe actuellement elle est contestée à
l'intérieur même de la Russie les gens
se posent des questions de la façon que
la guerre est menée par les généraux
russes et ce qu'on voit
quand on voit un groupe qui lui se
démarque essaie de prendre plus de
notoriété pour éventuellement permettre
à son à son chef monsieur prigogène
avoir un peu plus d'attention et même
être en mesure d'influencer ce qui se
passe directement au Kremlin alors si
ces deux types de bataille qu'on voit il
y en a une qui est vraiment politique
alors l'énoncé de de Wagner aujourd'hui
qu'ils auraient pris la ville c'est un
énoncé qui est qui est faux parce que
les troubles les troupes Ukrainiens sont
encore en place et ils combattent encore
ce secteur là c'est pour ça que de
donner tout de suite raison à Monsieur
Prigogine ce serait pour les Russes le
consacrer et lui dire qu'il est meilleur
que l'armée russe alors c'est pour ça
que l'armée russe est pas est pas prêt
non plus appuyer saisir bon c'est très
intéressant parce que finalement il a
toujours été présenté cette oligares
comme un très très proche de Poutine
mais à trop marqué des points avec le
groupe Wagner il pourrait ressembler à
un adversaire aussi oui
il n'a pas encore émis d'une façon
claire mais évidemment si Poutine
devient de plus en plus à risque et son
leadership est contesté et qui a un
mouvement pour le s'en débarrasser ou
l'écarter du pouvoir des gens comme pris
d'origine vont être les premiers à
revendiquer puis avoir prendre la place
qui est libre alors où il va y avoir une
confrontation dans ce niveau-là sans
faute bon parlez-nous de solidars cette
petite ville là qui semble-t-il est
complètement dévasté les images parlent
d'elles-mêmes d'ailleurs si la ville
tombe dans les mains des Russes est-ce
que c'est un gain important pour la
Russie alors on nous parle de cette mine
de sel très grand paraît-il vraiment
très profond aussi on pourrait même
cacher des temps que des armements
semblent-ils alors quel gain ça
représenterait pour la Russie alors
c'est un gain qui serait plus je vous
dirais c'est pas vraiment un gros gain
stratégique parce que il faut qu'il
fasse plus que ça il faut qu'il y ait
autour de backmouth en passant par
Solidar et encerclé backmod c'est
seulement qu'une première étape
solidaire par contre il y a des mines de
sel les tunnels qui sont dans les mines
de sel sont une longueur totale
d'environ de 200 km alors on peut placer
des gens un peu placer des armes
là-dedans un peu comme on a vu à Mario
Paul dans la mine de dans le complexe de
azophtal où les Ukrainiens s'étaient
étrangers ça a pris beaucoup d'efforts
avec des loger alors les Russes ont peur
que ça devienne comme ça pour eux c'est
de prendre cet endroit là le plus
rapidement possible et de là est un
tremplin pour encercler la ville de
backmouth parlez-nous de l'aspect
sanglant de des batailles qui sont
menées le même des proches conseillers
de Monsieur Zelinski j'ai écouté ce qui
se passe là-bas on n'a pas vu ça
ailleurs du tout en Ukraine des gens des
analyses faisaient référence même à une
guerre de tranchée comme dans le temps
de la première guerre mondiale en quoi
c'est particulier ce qui se passe là-bas
c'est particulier parce que en fait les
Ukrainiens va défendre sa défend très
bien c'est les adversaires Wagner qui
eux étaient un groupe de mercenaires ne
se plie pas du tout aux conventions
internationales alors la Convention de
Genève et tous ces conventions là il y a
il respecte rien alors il deviennent
vraiment ça devient vraiment une guerre
sauvage et ça ça fait un petit peu
plaisir je vous dirais Poutine parce que
ces Wagner qui se salit les mains et
s'il y avait des revendications au
tribunal international de la paix les
ruches pourraient dire bah c'est pas
nous on était pas là c'est un groupe
privé un peu comme il y a déjà mentionné
pour l'intervention de Wagner en Syrie a
dit les mêmes mots alors mais le
problème c'est s'il est trop de place à
Wagner comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure Wagner pour le groupe de Wagner
avec prigognes pourraient lui
revendiquer par la suite il y a des
victoires
c'est très délicat pour Monsieur Poutine
la motivation des troupes de Wagner
d'abord c'est des gens qui sont
paraît-il mieux payés les soldats russes
et c'est des gens qui sont même recrutés
directement dans les prisons leur promet
de les grassiers si ils s'enrôles
pendant un certain nombre de mois mais
on se dit par contre si vous quittez on
va vous pourchasser et on va vous
exécuter c'est extrêmement sévère alors
ils ont un offre de joints de groupe
avec pour faire un service de 6 mois et
après 6 mois ils sont libérés de tout
ils peuvent retourner à leur vie normale
s'il survivent actuellement le taux de
survie de ces gens-là c'est environ 5 à
6 semaines sur le champ de bataille
alors il y a et le pourquoi c'est qu'ils
sont mal entraînés et puis deviennent la
chair à canon nécessairement en voyant
ensemble plusieurs cassettes de déserter
des déserteurs sont repris et sont
sévèrement puni sont même tués par par
leurs anciens confrères
de cette guerre-là dans tous les cas de
toutes les de toutes les points de vue
monsieur censé bon c'est dramatique mais
c'est intéressant de décoder de
comprendre que derrière cette guerre il
y a aussi des
et des jeux de pouvoir en Russie merci
de votre regard ce soir merci Madame
Brelet en soirée pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI
[Musique]